- We are doing a very special round
of Drew's Crew and A.
So, let's get into it.
First step is a question right
here in our studio audience.
It's Yvette Atiles and I would
love to know your question.
- Hi Drew, hi Mikel.
So I'm in the process of
purchasing my new home.
- [Drew] Congratulations.
- And as you know, it's very expensive.
So my question is, what
furniture should I be thinking
about investing and what
furniture should I sort of think
about buying in the cheaper end of it?
- So, here's the thing with that.
Typically you want to spend
the big bucks on the things
or the surfaces that you're
gonna touch the most,
i.e. like your bed, your
sofa, your coffee table,
things that you're gonna
have a lot of high traffic.
Now you can kick back a little bit
on smaller things like
bookcases, floating shelves,
things that people aren't
gonna touch as much.
It's a matter of finding things
that are not so expensive,
but functional and if it's like crappy,
keep it somewhere up hidden so
nobody even sees that thing.
- Okay, thank you Yvette
for your question.
(audience applauds)
All right next is a social media question
from Rosalia Flores on Facebook,
and she asks spring cleaning my makeup.
What should I keep in my
go to arsenal for makeup
and how should I know to edit?
- Oh, we love a makeup edit, right Drew?
We love this.
Well, the thing is you want
something minimal, right?
You don't want loads
and loads of products.
So for that, you wanna think
about multitasking products.
Number one, I would say
for, the spring is coming.
You want something that is a
tinted moisturizer with an SPF.
You want your skin to look
polished every day, not overdone.
You want people to basically
compliment your skin,
not your makeup.
The second thing I would say for spring
is a bright color eyeshadow, right?
We are seeing that all over
as a big, big trend coming up,
blue, coral, green, anything you, I mean,
it could be a line or it
could be a smudge on the eye,
something bright and bold.
- [Drew] I love that.
- Right.
- I think go to the Milk Makeup website.
It's my favorite company.
RMS makes a great little mini palette
that I'm obsessed with that
has a highliner and a bronzer
and a little lip and cheek.
- Yep.
- And one thing I've realized
is that I have usually bought
a lot of my products in bulk.
Big mistake.
Don't do it.
I've had to throw out a few things
because they went past the two year mark.
And so I would also keep
it a minimalist approach
when you're buying your
products and cleansers,
skin care and makeup, you can
always go out and buy another.
But the fact that I have
a few that are expired,
breaks my heart and makes
me feel so wasteful.
- You would rather your
product run out than it go off.
- [Drew] Yes, exactly.
- Save the bulk buying
for the toilet roll.
- Agree.
(everyone laughing)
And for that, I have a
new bamboo toilet paper
that took me a minute to get
used to but I'm all for it now.
- [Zanna] Ooh Really?
- [Ross] Do tell.
- It saves trees and paper
towels and toilet paper.
And they it's completely sustainable.
No tree.
- Does it save your bum?
- It's a.
(audience applauds)
- Again, it took me a
second to get used to.
- I have the toilet paper too
and you know, she's a sturdy paper.
If you know what I mean.
- She's not as, she
doesn't feel like velvet
but she's not killing trees.
- [Ross] Exactly.
- So, if I to take one for the team.
(audience applauds)
- [Zanna] Amazing.
- I'm going to.
Thank you Ozalia so much.
(upbeat music)